[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
[Applaus]
Bild es ist Dienstag der 13 juli
2021 Hochsommer in der Hauptstadt die
Temperaturen kratzen an der 30° Marke
der Himmel ist strahlend blau kaum eine
Wolke ist zu sehen seit knapp dre Wochen
sind Sommerferien in Berlin die
Flughäfen und Bahnhöfe sind voll mit
Urlaubern die es in die Ferne zieht so
auch am Bahnhof Südkreuz Berlins
zweitgrößtten Bahnhof knapp 2.000
Menschen passieren diesen am Tag um
16:30 Uhr betreten zwei Männer die
Eingangshalle des Bahnhofs in der
Menschenmenge gehen die beiden beinah
unter würden sie nicht einen großen
schwarzen Koffer zu zweit durch das
Bahnhofsgebäude Schleppen der eine hält
ihn hinten der andere vorne der
stoffkoffer ist schwer er wiegt etwas
mehr als 60 kg so viel wie Mariam h
deren Leiche im schwarzen Koffer
versteckt ist die zwei Männer sind
mariams Brüder und gerade dabei ihren
Körper zu
beseitigen der Mord an Mariam h
schockiert im Sommer 2021 ganz
Deutschland die brutal Hintergründe der
Tat und insbesondere der perfide Versuch
ihre Leiche zu verstecken hat es so in
dieser Form in Deutschland noch nicht
gegeben gleichzeitig wird der Fall aber
auch zum Politikum über Integration und
die Rolle der Frau in muslimisch
geprägten Ländern er entfacht eine
Debatte über gescheiterte Integration
und den Begriff des sogenannten
Ehrenmords der Mord an Mariam h ist das
Thema unserer heutigen Folge von tatout
Deutschland und dazu herzlich willkommen
mein Name ist Mirko Kasimir schön dass
ihr wieder mit dabei seid und ich bin
Tony Haier hallo
zusammen wir beginnen heute in
Afghanistan in den 2010er Jahren die
Taliban lassen das Land nicht zur Ruhe
kommen Selbstmordanschläge nehmen zu
denen meistens Zivilisten zum Opfer
fallen die Sicherheitslage verschlimmert
sich stetig immer mehr Menschen flüchten
aus dem Land am
Hindukusch unter anderem auch ein Teil
der Familie h die
Brüder Sowi deren älteren Schwester
Mariam damals 29 mit ihrem Mann Habib
und ihren zwei Kindern Jusuf kommt in
Bayern unter der Rest der Familie lebt
in verschiedenen flüchtlingsunterkünften
in
Berlin trotz des neuen Lebens im Westen
lebt Mariam weiterhin sehr angepasst sie
geht zur Moschee gibt fremden Männern
nicht die Hand und kleidet sich
traditionell sie legt ihren hup nur ab
wenn sie unter Frauen ist mit ihren
Brüdern hat Mariam viel Kontakt kommt of
bei zu Hause vorbei kocht und macht Ihre
Wäsche Mariam verdient nebenher etwas
Geld als Putzfrau einen Teil ihres
Geldes gibt sie an ihre Brüder weiter
Mariam ist mit ihrem Ehemann Habib
verheiratet seitdem sie 16 ist es ist
das Ergebnis einer Zwangsheirat in
Afghanistan um Ihrer Familie einen
besseren Stand in der Gesellschaft zu
verschaffen Habib ist
gewalttätig und das ändert sich auch
nicht durch die gemeinsame Flucht nach
Berlin im Jahr 2017 eskaliert ein Streit
so sehr dass Habib die gemeinsamen
Kinder angreift und versucht Mariam mit
kochendem Wasser zu übergießen die
Polizei muss
einschreiten und dann hat Mariam genug
sie lässt sich von ihrem Ehemann
scheiden setzt ein annäherungsverbot
gegen ihn durch und zieht mit ihren zwei
Kindern aus der gemeinsamen Unterkunft
aus ein wirklich drastischer Schritt für
die Mutter der nicht ohne Folgen bleiben
soll Habib lauert ihr permanent auf
beschimpft sie und droht ihr mit dem Tod
mariams Vater der weiterhin in
Afghanistan lebt verstößt seine Tochter
Mariam hätte durch die Scheidung die
Ehre der Familie verletzt und als wäre
das alles nicht schlimm genug hat
mariams Scheidung auch Einfluss auf ihre
Beziehung zu ihren Brüdern denn anders
als ihr Vater brechen sie nicht den
Kontakt zu ihrer Schwester ab sie
besuchen Mariam fort an beinah jedes
Wochenende Jusuf kommt dafür extra aus
seinem Wohnort Donau W in Bayern
angereist
m und Jusuf kontrollieren was Maria
macht wo sie ist und mit wem sie ist
wenn ihnen etwas nicht passt schlagen
Sie Mariam so fest dass sie häatome am
ganzen Körper hat auch ihre Kinder
werden Opfer dieser Übergriffe MADI und
Jusuf sind ihnen gegenüber gewalttätig
außerdem versuchen die Brüder
Informationen über Mariam bei den
Kindern herauszubekommen mariams Tochter
die zu diesem Zeitpunkt nicht einmal ein
Teenager ist versuchen sie zu zwingen
ein K kftuch zu tragen je va Jusuf und
mi versuchen ihre Wertvorstellungen bei
ihrer Schwester und deren Kindern
durchzusetzen desto weniger halten sie
sich selbst an diese MADI gilt als
psychisch labil er verletzt sich selbst
und flüchtet sich deshalb in den Gras
und Alkoholkonsum sein älterer Bruder
Jusuf hat in Donau W ein Verhältnis mit
einer verheirateten Frau die beiden
haben sogar ein Kind Jusuf seine
Liebhaberin und Ihr Kind leben gemeinsam
mit dem Ehemann seineer Affäre und
wiederum deren zwei gemeinsam Kindern
zusammen eine wirklich sehr seltsame
Patchwork Familie und eine ordentliche
Doppelmoral ja aber zurück zu Maria
nachdem sie ihren Mann verlassen hat
zieht sie mit ihren Kindern in eine
Notunterkunft dort kriegt die kleine
Familie einen Familienhelfer zugeteilt
farok K der Sozialpädagoge unterstützt
Mariam beim deutschlerern und etweigen
behördengäng die beiden kommen sich
näher verbringen viel Zeit miteinander
im Jahr 2018 treffen Jusuf und MADI
Familienhelfer farok K zufällig in
mariams Unterkunft die Brüder sind
empört ein fremder Mann habe nichts in
mariams Zimmer zu suchen josu bedroht
ihn sogar mit einem Messer und trotz
solcher Gewaltausbrüche von mariams
Brüdern und der Angst über die Folgen
einer neuen Liebe verlieben sich Mariam
und faroka und werden ein
paar wenn sie zusammen sind träumen sie
von großen Reisen die Sie unternehmen
wollen farok und Mariam wollen
zusammenziehen und heiraten nach di
Jahren heimlicher Beziehung will Mariam
ihre Liebe endlich öffentlich machen
aber es wird ihr Todesurteil
sein am Montag den 12 juli 2021 steigt
Jusuf in einen Zug von donav World nach
Berlin am nächsten Morgen rufen er und m
Mariam an die beiden wissen von ihren
Plänen eine Wohnung zu finden und
erzählen ihrer Schwester sie hätten eine
Dreizimmerwohnung in Neuköln für Sie
gefunden was Mariam nicht weiß die
vermeintlich freie Wohnung ist
eigentlich ein Zimmer in dem Hostel in
dem MADI lebt nach dem Telefonat fahren
die beiden Brüder zu Primark am
Alexanderplatz um 11:2 Uhr kaufen Sie
dort den schwarzen großen Koffer die
Auswahl treffen sie nicht spontan eine
Woche vorher hat Jusuf unter einem
falschen Vorwand Mariam und ihre Kinder
gewogen und ausgemessen wie die
Ermittlungen zeigen werden googelten die
Brüder im Anschluss Koffer bis 70 KG
Berlin gegen 13 Uhr betritt Mariam die
Wohnung in der sie vermeintlich ihr
neues Leben beginnen soll nach
Auffassung des Gerichts spielen sich die
nächsten Minuten so
ab sofort überwältigen Jusuf und MADI
ihre ältere Schwester einer der beiden
fixiert mariams Hände hinter dem Rücken
mit Klebeband danach kleben sie ihr Mund
und Nase zu Mariam kriegt jetzt keine
Luft mehr zusätzlich strangolieren die
Brüder die 34-Jährige noch mit einem
schwarzen Tuch ob das Verkleben oder das
erdrosseln mariams todschluss endlich
verursacht konnten die Ermittler nicht
mehr
feststellen um die Ehre der Familie die
ihrer Meinung nach durch mariams Taten
beschmutzt wurde wiederherzustellen
schneidet einer der beiden Brüder noch
die Kehle der Toten Mariam durch der
Schnitt ist so tief dass er bis zu ihrer
Halswirbelsäule reicht
die Leiche ihrer Schwester Zwängen mi
und Jusuf in den zuvor gekauften Koffer
und rufen ein Taxi welches sie mit
mariams versteckter Leiche zum Bahnhof
Südkreuz bringt und so finden wir uns in
der Situation wieder die wir bereits zu
Beginn der Folge geschildert haben zu
zweit schleppen Jusuf und MADI den
Koffer durch das Bahnhofsgebäude der
untere Teil des Trolleys ist stark
ausgebult auf den Aufnahmen der
Überwachungskameras kann man beinah
mariams Körper erahnen an gleich dre
legen Jusuf und MADI erstmal eine
Verschnaufspause ein MADI dadelt ganz
entspannt am Handy und Jusuf träumt in
der Gegen herum zwischen der Bank und
einem Mülleimer steht der schwarze
Koffer neben den Brüdern und mariams
Leiche sitzen unwissende Mitfahrer die
auf ihren Zug warten um 17:52 Uhr hiefen
die Brüder den Koffer in einen ICE nach
München stundenlang fahren die beiden
Männer durch die Bundesrepublik bis sie
an ihrem Ziel Donau ankommen wie später
im Prozess herauskommt lassen sich die
Brüder am Bahnhof von jusufs Freundin
abholen nichts ahnen transportiert diese
mariams Leiche im Auto am nächsten
Morgen fährt mi mit einem ICE zurück
nach Berlin Jusuf lässt sich von seiner
Geliebten Sparten Schaufel und
Handschuhe im Baumarkt kaufen wie die
Zeit berichtet bittet Jusuf danach seine
Freundin ihn zu einem Waldgebiet zu
führen wo die beiden in der
Vergangenheit Pilze sammeln
waren jusufs Freundin FT mit ihrem Auto
vor er folgt ihr in seinem an einer
Stelle überholt Jusuf plötzlich seine
Partnerin teilt ihr mit er müsse Pipi
machen und wolle spazieren gehen seine
Freundin solle im geparkten Auto warten
jusf fährt davon und wie die
Ermittlungen ergeben werden vergräbt er
im Anschluss mariams Leiche in dem
verlassenen
Waldgebiet doch das alles Wissen mariams
Freunde Kinder und ihr neuer Partner in
Berlin nicht
unmittelbar nach ihrem Verschwinden
meldet farok Mariam als vermisst er
druckt Flyer und verteilt diese in der
Innenstadt MADI und Jusuf geraten
schnell in den Fokus der Ermittler durch
die Auswertung Ihrer Handydaten können
die Einsatzkräfte den Weg der Brüder von
madis Unterkunft bis zum Südkreuz
nachverfolgen auf den
Überwachungskameras entdecken Sie dann
die Brüder wie sie mit dem großen
schwarzen ausgebollten Koffer in den ICE
nach Donau W steigen der grausame
Verdacht dass Mariam im Koffer sein
könnte der macht sich breit und ein
Leichenspürhund scheint diese Vermutung
zu bestätigen das Tier schlägt an einer
bahnhofsrolltreppe am Südkreuz an am 3
August fast dre Wochen nach ihrem
Verschwinden nehmen die Ermittler mi und
Jusuf fest obwohl zu diesem Zeitpunkt
mariams Leiche noch gar nicht gefunden
ist dafür kommt jusufs Freundin in Donau
WT ins Spiel nach ihrer Zeugenaussage
führt sie die Ermittler zu dem Ort
nachdem sich Jusuf erkundigte und an den
er sich von ihr hinführen ließ hier
finden die Einsatzkräfte mariams Grab
ein nicht mal einen halben Meter tiefes
Erdloch neben einer illegalen müllkeppe
darin liegt sie in Embryonalstellung
über mariams Kopf ist eine blaue
Plastiktüte gezogen ihre Hände sind mit
Klebeband
gefesselt unter dem Klebeband finden die
Ermittler die Finger eines
plastikhandchuhs an dieser sind den
arpuren von MADI es besteht kein Zweifel
mehr daran dass die Brüder am Tod ihrer
Schwester beteiligt sind MADI und Jusuf
bleiben in
Haft schnell steht die Frage im Raum ob
die Brüder von ihrer Familie aus
Afghanistan angestiftet worden sein
könnten beweisen können die Ermittler
das nicht sie gehen jedoch davon aus
dass Jamal der dritte Bruder der mit
nach Deutschland floh Mitwisser war zum
Tatzeitpunkt sitzt dieser jedoch in Haft
nachdem er jemanden mit einem Messer
angegriffen hatte die Brüder hatten
jedoch regelmäßig Kontakt zu ihm Jusuf
besuchte ihn sogar wenige Tage nach
mariams verschwinden in der JVA in
Berlin nach Angaben einer Mitarbeiterin
sollen sich die beiden zur Begrüßung in
den Arm gelegen haben Jusuf habe geweint
und Jamal habe ihn
getröstet zu den Vorwürfen äußert sich
Jamal jedoch nie im Oktober
2022 hängt er sich in seiner
Zelle im März 2022 beginnt der Prozess
gegen die Brüder Jusuf und MADI am
Landgericht Berlin der Vorwurf Mord die
Verteidiger der Brüder haben hingegen
eine komplett andere Auffassung darüber
was am 13 juli passiert sein soll
demnach sei mariams Tod ein tragischer
Unfall gewesen josuf habe sie
versehentlich zu Tode gewirkt nachdem
sie schlecht über ihre Eltern gesprochen
habe die habe er nur aufgeschlitzt weil
mariams Leiche nicht in den Koffer
passte den er zufällig dabei hatte und
MADI half nur beim Transport des
Koffers das Gericht überzeugt diese
Version nicht im Februar
2023 nach 11 Monaten und 42
Verhandlungstagen wird das Urteil
gefällt der Richter verurteilt die
beiden Brüder zu lebenslanger Haft wegen
Mordes die Tat sei an Niedertracht kaum
zu
überbieten die Brüder hätten ihre
Schwester ermordet weil Mariam ihr Leben
nach eigenen Vorstellungen führen wollte
dieses Recht dieses Lebensrecht haben
sie ihr
abgesprochen die Brüder gehen
unmittelbar nach dem Urteil in Revision
heißt die Brüder MADI und Jusuf werden
die Berliner Justiz noch länger
beschäftigen und die Kinder von Mariam
noch lange keinen Frieden finden
können die Geschichte von Mariam und
ihren Brüdern es hätte eine gute
Geschichte sein können gemeinsam
entkommen sie der Taliban in Afghanistan
in Deutschland bauen Sie sich ein neues
Leben auf Mariam befreit sich aus den
Fängen ihres gewalttätigen Ehemannes und
findet eine neue Liebe doch se Jahre
nach ihrer Einreise ist Mariam tot zwei
ihrer Brüder sitzen im Gefängnis und der
dritte Bruder ist tot auf einem Friedhof
in Berlin steht ein kleiner weißer Zaun
er grenzt ein Stück Wiese ein sie ist
verlassen und ungepflegt das Gras
wuchert unkontrolliert zwischen den
Grasbüscheln steckt ein kleines gelbes
Schild darauf steht 16c 19 kein Name
kein Geburts oder Todestag hier liegt
Mariam begraben hier findet Mariam ihre
letzte
Ruhe damit sind wir am Ende unserer
heutigen Folge wir haben mit Quellen der
Zeit SZ Berliner Kurier FAZ Spiegel und
unserer eigenen Berichterstattung
gearbeitet wir freuen uns dass ihr auch
heute wieder mit dabei wart schaltet
auch beim nächsten Mal wieder mit ein
und wenn ihr Anregungen Kritik oder
fallvorschläge habt dann schreibt uns
gern eine Nachricht die Infos dazu die
findet ihr in den Show Notes bis dahin
passt auf Euch auf und bis zum nächsten
mal eure Toni und euer
Merkur
dir hat diese Folge von Tatort
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Rusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Hermann wir hören uns bei tatout
Deutschland